Rich Eisen show on DIRECTV's audience
Channel after this one the NFL Network
host and rich is running the 40 at the
combine again and the run benefits st.
Jude's Children's Research Hospital
and you run the 40 post your video to
social media using run rich run and also
hashtag st. Jude the video may be
featured on NFL Network go to NFL calm /
run rich run to donate what kind of
shape you in rich I'm in the best shape
of my career what is the strategy and
running the 40 and when will you run
said forty I run said forty Sunday we
here at Monday and my strategy is I
actually trained this time around Suzy's
as you know is my wife and she's very
strident convincing for years she's been
telling me to actually train and I did
at jeg lasers Jim unbreakable
performance in Los Angeles so I actually
trained for it for this first time and I
think I feel good damn feel good feel
good going in I'm just gonna get down on
that line and run a hole for the best
personal best
cramps take take it one step at a time
yes I hope so I hope so I you know I I
feel good I really do and it's you know
raising as much money as we possibly can
for st. Jude's I appreciate you
mentioning the link to donate didn't
Deion Sanders help you with well you
know I mean we we have for years my
prior to the charitable aspect of it my
two main concerns were one I would get
hurt doing it and two it would jump the
shark and one year to keep it going and
switch it up we had him as Leon
sandcastle run with me and Deion ran
with me backwards for the first 20 yards
running backwards and he was beating me
and then he turned around and jogged the
rest of the way backwards he was stride
for stride with me in an afro running
twenty yards yeah so he did that is
is Cuyler murmuring around the 40 you
know what I am not I haven't gotten in
the building yet but it seems like he's
not gonna throw which is patently
disappointing to everyone with the NFL
Network and I think fans who want to see
him throw and I haven't heard that from
him yet and you're hearing he might be
competitive and and do it anyway because
it's going to be really awkward for him
standing out there in a in a sweatshirt
and his sweatpants while the rest of the
players in his group go out there and
sling it and it definitely does run
counter to him saying he loves the sport
and he doesn't throw it I'm not going to
sit here in states can affect his draft
status I mean Sam Darnell didn't throw
he went third overall Andrew Luck didn't
throw I mean the number of players that
didn't throw and still went at the draft
position they were hoping for I've lost
track but you know it all it's going to
do is also lend to two more rumor and
more conjecture and you know I'm already
hearing right now what that is is he
clocked in at 207 which is 22 pounds
more than his playing weight we could
see him on the NFL Network today walking
to the measurement area
pounding water as he was getting onto
the scale and now the talk already is
the reason why he's not throwing is he's
never been 207 pounds and he hasn't
thrown it that weight and they have no
idea how that might affect his
performance and then there's the
conjecture well he won't be 207 when
he's drafted or what he starts playing
so what does this all mean unless he
throws that's that's obviously the voids
gonna be filled with that conversation
it feels like he ruined a good story or
story we could still run with because he
measured over 510 you know it felt like
if he was under 510 then there's more
drama more speculation at 510 is he now
tall enough to be drafted number one
overall well he's now he's now in
Russell Wilson territory and
in terms of the measurements and so you
could sit here and say that that checks
the box that he's he's he's or at least
he's checked the boxes that Russell
Wilson did but Russell Wilson I would I
think as you know as you know him very
well
he's an outlier he's he's an exception
so you know could Murray be another one
of those yeah I guess but in terms of
you know ruining a story you you said
you said you had a first hand as you
know and maybe your your your listeners
and viewers don't know you know when
we're next door to each other at Super
Bowls you with my show coming on after
yours an audience so when you guys have
guests on live we can we kind of pre
tape them before or after for our show
and air it while they're in the building
so before you had calamari I had him and
sent him down the hall to you yeah and I
had the same exact experience with him
where he could not or would not did not
answer the question are you gonna play
football or baseball creating an absurd
narrative I mean this there's there's no
other way to describe it other than
awkward and absurd
and so I'm just wondering where he's
getting his advice now and does it
really matter though I'm really not
gonna sit here and say he's getting
terrible advice and he's good he's gonna
fall in the in the draft and how dare he
it really only takes one and it could be
Arizona that one but right now I
honestly don't know what the game plan
is for his narrative creation but I I
when I was done I wanted to grab him and
point to the side and just say no no not
grab him and shake him I just I wanted
to grab him and just pulling to the side
and say off the air you know hey you got
to understand what this world is and you
looked bad and and you know from an
optics if I'm a GM or a coach and I'm
looking at this like that's what I want
to see I want to sit down with with
Kyler Murray if I'm an NFL team and just
talk to him
I don't care about him running I don't
care about him throwing I don't care
about his height
I don't care about his weight I want to
know who are you what is your
personality because he's not Baker
Mayfield he's not Russell Wilson when it
comes to personality so what who are you
what are you and what do you want to be
those are the things that I want to know
from Kyler Murray before I even consider
taking him at the first round pick yeah
and what motivates you who's in your
who's in your ear and how is that going
to you know affect your your play or
your your your approach to your job once
we get you in the building that said you
know the conversation here is that he is
really special and is a unicorn and at
his height or whatever you want to say
about his measurements he is going to be
a major difference maker when he gets in
the league I just don't know if any of
that is the Baker Mayfield effect
because they're from the same school
they both won the Heisman they're from
the same system that puts people into
the league and obviously can succeed and
and I think what everybody is reading
into him and potentially accurately is
that if he is going to be drafted at the
top of this draft then the
transformation of the NFL and its
offenses in the way that people evaluate
talent coming from the collegiate level
will officially come out of the 20th
century and the entire league will be
all-in now on the 5:00 widespread RPO
whatever you want to call it because
again he has the same measurements as
Russell Wilson and Russell was even
downgraded by people to go into the
third round and Russell cut weight to
get to his weight Kyler was pounding
water to get to his which is going to be
again like I said the question mark that
fills the void between now and whenever
he does throw or whatever he has drafted
and whatever he does actually take a
snap he's gonna be like so okay did you
do this so you could try and get drafted
top ten or can you play it this way you
didn't throw it that weight at the
combine blah blah blah and I don't think
as you put you
I do believe Danna I you know I've known
you for a long time I do believe
calamari might be the only interview
subject you reminded that the microphone
was working so I don't think he can okay
I had heard when we're the we've been at
these places and I sometimes if you
interview somebody before me and then I
do it live you know I'm always curious
how it went and I had heard that you
interviewed Cuyler Murray yeah and and
the word was it didn't go well so by the
time you got done taping and then he was
coming down the hall I had already
gotten word where somebody in my ear
said the interview on ice and showed it
didn't go well and I'm going oh all
right well I had him on earlier in the
year during the season and Cuyler Murray
was very good entertaining personality
and then all of a sudden I don't know
who told him hey don't say anything but
say nice things about Gatorade it was
you know like paying fealty to Qualcomm
right I mean so it was really awkward it
was really really because the only
question you wanted to ask him and the
only answer that was really of most
important so what are you gonna do are
you playing baseball or football and I
don't know why he decided to go into you
know interview settings without having a
plan on how to answer it yeah so you
know it was really but we did also Don
our set have a setup where we had all
the players who came through have a
contest as to who could throw the ball a
ball a football through a hole about you
know 15 yards away a throwing contest
and Kyler Murray did throw on the Rich
Eisen show and at this point in time
that might be the only time he throws
between the national semifinal and his
pro day so I've got exclusive footage
down I now know
want to use it rising rate is taking
their heads rich yeah we did the arm
strength yes he Smith he smoked okay
okay how about this you tested arm
strength
I tested act yes together yeah together
our six-hour block we've got what
everybody yes we do
how about that we had our own combine
yes there is an iron Patrick
Rich Eisen but still a team Dan rich is
at the combine when does the NFL Network
coverage of the combine star we're on
it's me and Daniel Jeremiah this time
around is Mayock will be with their
Raiders and so we start 9:00 a.m.
tomorrow with the running backs and
offensive line group then the tight ends
and quarterbacks get out with the wide
outs on Saturday defenders Sunday and
then Monday is uh defensive backs in my
run so alright that's the that's we be
sent around and riches show will be
following this show coming up in about
twenty minutes on audience 339 DirecTV
didn't Daniel Jeremiah give us a new
term holy when we got like waist benders
and all the other ones yeah but he had a
word though didn't he slower body twist
yeah lower bodies which yeah oh my god
yeah and is that one would say that's a
measurable Dan I would think I have no
idea but it's it's lower body twitch
yeah I mean may arch had all of those
heavy legged waist benders ankle flexion
my favorite Mayock ISM was he's quicker
than fast I never understood what that
meant and I sat next to him for 15 years
but that's all being brought to the
Raider it would be unbelievable that
Mayock after all this time that his
first election could possibly be and I
doubt it would even though Gruden did
call David Derek Carr is uh his uh his
franchise quarterback today and he did
not for now it like Steve calm did to
Josh Rosen yesterday yeah it would be
amazing if Tyler Murray was mike Mayock
first draft choice as a general matter
that would be that would be unbelievable
but we shall see
thank you rich take care of deep my Rich
Eisen NFL Network and the Rich Eisen
show follows this one coming up at noon
eastern nine Pacific for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]